give me a summary imbalance Middleton
step back
[Applause]
now off the basketball before the red
light comes on
yes he did I told you it was good Wow
[Applause]
where's up on the honesty honest tight
to Kevin Love forcing to throw away let
so
[Applause]
they're learning but and will be better
because of in the long run you won't sag
is so big
since Yanis trilling siakam not quitting
on the play takes it away ahead for heel
back for Jana Jana side of the combo and
George Hill beautiful basketball first
the great defensive play give me that
cp3 get it early get it back watch that
bounce pass no-look number from George
Hill and then get out the way in
backboard swayin Monster Jam mean bug
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
sterling Brown chicks in Hill in bounds
for Yanis three seconds remaining in the
first quarter three on the way out of
the kupo hits it beautiful beautiful
pull up in I'm 24 Milwaukee it's
exciting when there are multiple teams
do oh my that's exciting
every night of the season I mean look
there's no way the Kazi could had any
idea was about to happen it's been a
very solid second game as a blazer for
Carmelo Anthony ten point lead
oh man look at this play baseline spin
reverse dunk it didn't stay down
five threes in the third quarter Porter
by Matthews you notice when is it
anybody to lead and they have the worst
defensive field goal percentage at that
range also so it's definitely an area
[Applause]
you know I know how to get those back
and he does it's 12/5 but lucky bleeding
New York
[Applause]
backside clear it out and then this one
here man up accountant Yana she's a
three-man defensive law
Milton back - yes
here's Janice right here you talk about
that wall where here's a little
Wallbanger and they made Harvey
[Applause]
Kumba in assists he has not missed a
game this season Jana what
look at this deep three here I mean this
is a couple of feet behind that
three-point line he had just previously
caldwell-pope shot clock at three great
defense here by Casey
[Applause]
goodness full of 6e gets a jump shot
it's going to be lights out many tickets
remaining for that game tomorrow night
so get on
great defense leading to that towards
him
[Applause]
the Amish 18 points the rim high field
goal percentage but at me doing the job
and be thought he got fouled on the rip
through a dedicate one tomorrow even
Chen Zoe's done giving Dante his first
points in the game
[Applause]
and again Jim Boylan against Chicago in
the
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's kind of POD that saddl get to the
old town road turned in too quickly and
those villanova products even shinzo and
Josh Hart such key figures for their
teams as Yonex scores inside for the
Bucks
is Bledsoe now check in with Jared
Greenberg you've got more on Zion what'd
he have Jer yeah after Sunday's loss to
Houston as Yanis gets the bucket and the
foul be a good effort gave us the steal
a head dead a couple chest gum tallest
Jefferson but Shey is putting his mark
on this game
[Applause]
that's spinning of inertia
here he is again with that kind of push
shot floater and YouTube for five from
the field here's a lot for Yas in
transition no contest if around won't
break with these two explosive players
right here you can Bluff pensive rebound
off the Miss that petticoat Post spins
gets inside and finishes
[Applause]